[Music]  still to come this season on the Real  Housewives of Miami  [Music]  I threw my neck out giving head once  mine is not popping  [Music]  I'm started calling the adoption agents  yes not so successfully  you have that Halloween party it was a  lot of girls this is no excuse  have you ever taken an Uber or a lift  anywhere by yourself I'm scared  your ex-boyfriend we know he told me I  was never in love with myself  Nicole sent me something mirror mirror  on the wall who's the fake one of all  what Larson's an arsonist  it was my job for that dumbass  accusation  and pretty do you know how many hi Judas  is stereotypes judgments you have to  overcome Nicole that was not  professional it was so rude what's wrong  with you  you don't know what I felt [ __ ] I'm not  gonna accept this apology because  yourself  you  are an [ __ ]  [Applause]  let's go down the spot  where we love to play